welcome to this five-minute gamer
playing hgts dot 10 Wow why can't they
just I'll name them Joe Smith or
something then you can know what you're
doing it what you're reading okay the
Kings Indian wats line maybe the upper
back add this recently in the open on my
orca answer the some Serbian Grandmaster
with a very nice position let's turn
this into a samish type of structure oh
that's nice h4 maybe immediately each
for this maybe h6 coming with the bishop
H 694 let me just get the night to f2
first that's always nice and b5 is
really just just not working here can i
play a banco with the pawn on e5
yeah I want to play G for h1 expand on
the King side okay let's let's prevent
it b5 now was a threat
hmm to see not quite sure does he want
to play Knight b6 maybe
now the promise the Queen does not have
many squares and can easily get trapped
a five for example is already a quite
serious let's do this threatening rook a
for Bishop t1 trapping the Queen for
example after b6 will happen to be five
there is 93 can be a very very a very
close call for the Queen 93 Quincy for
there's at least night xe5 i but then we
can take only five okay the funny trick
but I can do that right and now 93 or SE
playing night c4 after that 93 Quincy
495 is very nice with 96 coming 93 94
night be four ninety to ninety six mm
yeah come on let's not reinvent with him
already down one time
hmm yeah but I guess you must play
Knight c4 I mean what else is there
queen bee three looks looks very strange
I mean I can't even go nite see one of
everything else fails and here i thought
okay d to hanks and the rook hangs and
just flat hangs not just the exchange
isn't this winning night be three maybe
maybe clicked on that
hmm yeah this request resign just to win
right down it's it's a piece and a very
very good position that was a very weird
let's look let's look at this p 5 yeah
the computer wants to I this is Sam okay
the computers of course merciless it
wants to take play this Quincy for
Quincy one and now it sits in this this
big threat of audio here it's that's
even stronger but this is strong right
it is winning yeah it is start to to
doubt your judgment really if you're in
a better bed run like I am this this is
this is nice for white knight or winning
night be three years the toughest try
then I go look here Intendant there is
this problem with the rook yeah but
still that this is something that I
still would have needed to find I mean
the way he played it was was really
simple no black gets a piece down and
then will also lose all those ponzio 297
Bishop a 6 and so on well the g7 bishop
is is just just a dead piece okay thanks
for watching